I find the jump phenomenon so shocking
because and if you look at my life for
example coming here at nine and then
here at age 87 I'm four weeks shy having
this interview with you having really a
privileged life in the United States I
can only say good things about the
analysis I think there's a fantastic
nas's you know you have weaknesses i
have weaknesses that's intrinsic to life
but if you look at the overall balance
what this country is achieved you know
it's remarkable i was born in Vienna and
you know we Jews were being driven out
and if they stayed they were killed so I
had to get out in 1939 one year after
Hitler came and I won't understand how
people could listen to hide and Mozart
and Beethoven one day and beat up to
choose the next and so I thought I would
do this through intellectual history and
there was a wonderful major called
history and literature which was an
honors major everybody taking that major
small group of people had to write a
dissertation and I wrote my dissertation
on the attitude toward National
Socialism of three different writers or
different positions and the political
spectrum and while I was writing that I
met an a psychoanalyst actually was also
an auto story and earns Chris who said
if you want understand human mind you're
not going to do it through intellectual
history going to do it through
psychoanalysis and that's what led me to
psychoanalysis but the Harvard
experience nonetheless when you take
these liberal arts courses you asked to
write dissertations you're asked to
write essays and I got the experience of
being able to write about Dostoevsky and
Freud by Joe working on it for two or
three months so even though I didn't
master the subject i learned to feel
comfortable about extracting key ideas
and developing them you look at the
Germans the Austrians are more complex
but the Germans
could not have handled themselves better
after the Second World War it's a
transformed society they opened their
tolerant they brought a hundred thousand
Jews into Berlin because they thought
the jewish population had gotten so
small they wanted to really reestablish
situationally it's fantastic Angela
Merkel's response to my grits is so
emphatic in such a decent humanistic
response despite the fact that she's
been criticized and it has caused
serious problems but just to show you
how this people has transformed itself
from the horrors of the concentration
camp to being an absolutely decent
civilized society in a variety of realms
I think each of us is capable now being
brutal each of us capabie perfectly
decent depends upon the social
environment a famous American theologian
once said the capability of people for
good makes democracy desirable the
capability for evil makes democracy
necessary and I think this is true
there's the capability for evil in all
of us who would have thought five years
ago the Trump would be candidate for
president for major political party
inconceivable that America would do this
it clearly is a mistake I think even
Trump I see this is a mistake and yet
this wonderful country to which I'm
eternally grateful almost went off the
tracks the Republican Party might have
decided earlier you know we have a
number of very good candidates there
would not be dangerous for the country
bond we unite behind them and see what
we can do but I think they felt the
Trump because he was so outspoken but
never had a candidate was getting
attention for being outspoken at that
time it was not about erotic matters it
was just about you know this country is
not being run well we
business talents like my own to run it
when you see his business tell us and
that's a great either but so he startled
everybody with what appeared to be an
honestly a new bold vision and that
people found this attractive there are
any country and there in the United
States a number of people who are highly
dissatisfied there is a discrepancy in
the united states between people who
earn an enormous amount of money and
many people who just barely eke out a
living and that's a bothersome issue
that upsets many people and I think
Trump seemed for some incomprehensible
reason to be a solution to that we have
you know an african-american president
who I happen to think is that a
remarkable job but that this country
would elect him is very much to its
credit and we're now in a position of
possible electing a woman so a lot of
the built-in prejudices have been worked
through in the United States and now
being worked through in the United
States so we're not a perfect society
long if you had human beings you're
never going to have a perfect society
but we when you look around the world
we're pretty dude doing pretty darn well